bonsoir hélas bien les graves dérives
graves car nous allons nous amuser
pendant une demi heure face à
cet art de la rupture mais elle est
prête pour le boulevard
[Rires]
mais non j'ai pas de trottoir du
boulevard
joe biden répondait à une question du
journaliste au sujet de l'inflation le
chef de l'état pense vite que son micro
était éteint à murmurer une insulte
écouté
et on va se détendre un petit peu quand
même ce qui va suivre et sans trucage je
pense que quelqu'un du staff de l'elysée
à chauray la statue du président hô
musée grévin la pause et en haute-vienne
à côtés de jacqueline gourault et hop ni
vu ni connu je crois ce qu'il faut au
fond c'est qu'il doit y avoir un
équilibre entre les ressources locales
et aussi les ressources nationales on
vous a découvert comme sosie de jean
michel blanquer lors de ce happening
près de près du ministère l'éducation
nationale est en tout cas un très bon
déhanché mais plus de trois mois de
gloire c'est votre première
c'est votre première télé là comme ça
publiquement
alors c'est ma première télé en plateau
oui oui oui en tant que sosie en tant
que sosie et avec un peu de chance je
vais pas rester saisi si longtemps que
ça mais bonne année nouvel an
je n'ai jamais répondu à un écart qui
avait suscité de nombreuses réactions
jusqu'à la candidate valérie pécresse
pour qu'il avait apporté son soutien à
l'époque j'ai été déçu parce que jamais
je l'avais entendu gims communautariser
son discours mais aujourd'hui il semble
être revenu sur ses propos c'est dans un
entretien dans le journal du dimanche
qu'il a tenu à s'excuser cette vidéo je
le regrette totalement c'était un ovni
je ne communique pas comme ça
habituellement je ne voulais pas blesser
des gens la fois ça relève de l'intimé
on a déjà refusé la nationalité à à ce
monsieur moi je veux dire qu'un article
très simple du pose de civils sertic 21
24 nul ne peut être naturalisé ci ne
justifie de son assimilation à la
communauté française de manière générale
étonnant 10ème rigoriste c'est pas une
bonne preuve d'assimilation à la société
française et donc moi j'assume le fait
que des instructions sont très
clairement donné pour refuser la
nationalité française qu'on soit connu
ou pas connus lorsqu'on est tenant d'un
islam rigoriste on voulait ça au
quotidien parce que j'imagine qu'on doit
vous venez vos copains quand c'est venu
alors moi mais mes copains une vanne
depuis cinq ans au bout d'une semaine
ils ont vu la ressemblance donc ça c'est
évident vu
mais c'était resté au niveau de mes
copains et puis
là j'ai vu des militants qui ont
commencé à me vanner
bon voilà je n'ai pas toujours très bien
vécu je me suis même laissé pousser la
barbe alors je n'avais pas là-bas manque
de bol il s'est mis à avoir la barbe les
quelques mois c'est ouais à part ça
yannick jadot était ce matin l'invité de
france inter l'occasion pour le candidat
écolo de livrer sa définition de
l'écologie
l'écologie c'est pas prendre une douche
froide dans le noir une fois par semaine
tu préfères réponse à gagner au loto et
vivre sans amour ou réponse vais vivre
d'amour et d'eau fraîche mais fauché
[Musique]
banon moi cette phrase pas du tout mais
mon quelle année je vais d'amour et
d'eau fraîche j'en ai rien à faire de
l'eau je préfère l'argent parce que au
moins je préfère plonger dans une
limousine que pleurer dans un bus moi je
veux comprendre quelque chose je suis
pas mathématicien moi je suis un simple
citoyen
le pic du pétrole le pic du prix du
baril de pétrole c'était en août 2008
147 dollars
août 2008 via de ça il ya de cela 14 ans
on est bien d'accord en août 2008 le
prix était à 1 euro 20 à la pompe à 147
dollars le baril en euro 676 le litre de
gasoil 1 744 le sans plomb 95 1 808 pour
le 98 c'est en moyenne 10 centimes
d'euros supplémentaires par litre en un
mois seulement face à cela les
consommateurs s'adaptent comme ils
peuvent on est en janvier 2022 le prix
du baril est de 87 dollars
il lui prête à 1 euro 80 en moyenne elle
s'appelle les taxes et les impôts
expliquez moi vous préférez l'argent à
la banque complètement en gagner au loto
aura toujours des armes au hasard l'eau
fraîche ça va bien cinq minutes un car
j'aurai tout le bonheur du monde je
t'explique une chose à partir du grand
rodez multimillionnaire je serai dans ta
vie tu auras tout ce que tu veux tu
auras tout ce que tu ce soin
prétendument rajeunissant et un masque à
la feuille d'or une technique vendu
comme un traitement remontant à l'égypte
ancienne facturer la bagatelle de 350
euros
alors on va venir vraiment
réhydrater en profondeur les tissus
avoir une action bactéricide avoir
vraiment apaiser les pots avec un petit
peu d'imperfections
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur france 2 pour
une soirée exceptionnelle
nous avons décidé d'en remonter le temps
vous devrez vous ça va voir vraiment un
éclat énorme sur le teint et ça va voir
aussi une action anti-âge et
régénérantes
regarder à huy à oui je m'attendais pas
du tout à ça c'est magnifique c'est très
loin et là ça commence à bien craquelé
on voit donc la peau qui absorbe au fur
et à mesure les petites particules d'or
seulement sérieux
m
le mariage à nouveau à la noce on
s'attend à un nombre record d'oignons
cette année
donne une au niveau
cadet en chaîne
mathieu poissant digne on patauge dans
le potage
la courge mais voilà qui nous fait
armada à la verticale c'est l'histoire
de milly cette chienne qui s'était
échappé lors d'une promenade sur la
plage avec sa maîtresse et qui s'est
retrouvée prisonnière d'un marais
impossible d'y accéder à pied un vrai
casse tête pour les sauveteurs après
deux jours de tentatives les efforts de
la police des pompiers des garde-côtes
n'avaient toujours pas abouti il fallait
que milices se rendent dans une zone
précise du marais pour qu'ils puissent y
accéder et la récupérer une saucisse a
été attaché sur un drone afin de
l'attirer en dehors de cette zone très
marécageux et situé dans le sud de
l'angleterre
appâtés par l'odeur de la viande elle a
pu finalement retrouvé sa propriétaire
saine et sauve donc mes amis acheteurs
ici présents se joignent à moi pour vous
et vous avez une très belle après-midi
sur
antenne 2
ou pas
[Applaudissements]